bonsoir originaire d'alsace
j'ai commencé ma carrière d'enseignante
à paris et lorsque j'ai commencé ma
carrière
eh bien j'ai commencé de manière assez
classique puisque lors de ma formation
je n'ai jamais entendu parler de
pédagogie alternative de pédagogie
montessori lors d'un remplacement de six
mois dans une classe de cm1 dans un car
attaqué un quartier classé rep réseau
d'éducation prioritaire
j'ai vite compris qu'il me faudrait
trouver d'autres solutions puisque au
sein de sa classe 23 élèves il y avait 5
ans élève qu'il y avait un niveau de
lecture fragile plus de la moitié de la
classe ne savait pas non plus
reconnaître le vert dans une phrase il
ne savait pas résoudre un calcul
résoudre un problème simple ou mesure un
segment j'ai donc rapidement décidé de
mettre en place des groupes de travail
c'est-à-dire des enfants qui
travaillaient avec moi sur une nouvelle
notion ça me permettait de différencier
et de travailler en fonction du niveau
de chacun
pendant que les autres s'entraîner sur
deux ans des nouvelles des notions
qu'ils avaient déjà vu qu'ils avaient
déjà commencé à découvrir
pour cela j'ai dû utiliser du matériel
coloré ou des jeux le but était de
rendre sa ludique dans ses ateliers de
travail les enfants on découvrait ont
découvert une certaine liberté puisqu'il
avait le droit de se déplacer de
travailler ensemble et même de s'amuser
sa patte et petz il tout de suite
puisque les enfants
il n'avait pas l'habitude de cette
liberté ils ont donc longtemps testé les
limites
[Musique]
eh oui l'autonomie n'est pas forcément
confortable pour tout le monde mais pour
autant j'ai souhaité leur faire
confiance on a continué de cette manière
et blanc manger constater que les choses
améliorer le climat de la classe s'est
apaisé les enfants re découvrez un
plaisir ou ou le découvrir pour certains
même le plaisir d'apprendre et
reprenaient confiance en dieu
l'année suivante gros virage je suis
parti dans une petite section doivent un
quartier plutôt favorisé parisien 29
petits de 3 ans qui découvraient pour la
plupart la collectivité est en tout cas
à découvrir pour la première fois
l'école dans une classe de 29 ans c'est
beaucoup
il ya beaucoup il ya des enfants qui ont
oublié un petit peu par rapport à
d'autres qui prennent plus de place face
à ce constat j'ai encore chercher d
autres solutions et c'est là que j'ai lu
mon premier livre sur la pédagogie
montessori un pédagogie montessori ou
monde et peut-être un peu ce que c'est
la pédagogie montessori maria montessori
la pédagogie montessori on en parle
beaucoup c'est un sujet à la mode
pour autant ce n'est pas tout neuf comme
vous pouvez le voir maria montessori a
travaillé des années 1900 c'était
médecin pédagogue italienne et après
avoir longtemps observé les enfants elle
a élaboré un matériel de manipulation
spécifique qui aide les enfants dans
leur développement
ce matériel est présenté de manière
individuelle c'est à dire que on peut on
peut adapter le moment où on le présente
par rapport au rythme aux intérêts de
l'enfant donc un d apprentissage adapté
au rythme aux intérêts de chacun mais
pour autant un effet de groupe au total
tout de même dans d'autres moments une
fois que le pot matériel étaient
présentés les enfants pouvaient revenir
ce matériel dix vingt trente fois et
c'est tant mieux puisque les découvertes
en neurosciences un peu plus récentes
ont prouvé que c'est la répétition qui
ancre les apprentissages durant donc
cette année en petite section g demi en
place les premières activités montessori
c'était essentiellement des actes et de
vie très pratique c'est à dire des
activités où l'enfant s'entraîne à aux
gestes de la vie quotidienne pour gagner
en autonomie
il pouvait par exemple attraper des
objets et des pinces verser des liquides
donc ça permet donc de gagner un autre
regret en autonomie et ça travaille
aussi la motricité fine pour passer
ensuite à l'écrit ça permet aussi de
travailler la concentration ça c'est
très important pour toute la suite à ce
moment là je gardais encore des
activités plus classiques pour les
mathématiques et le français
par manque de formation et aussi un peu
parlant des moyens suite à cette année
où j'ai senti un vrai intérêt des
enfants pour cette pédagogie puisque ils
s'épanouissent et ils étaient contents
de faire ses activités où il découvrait
et gagner en autonomie
j'ai souhaité aller plus loin dans la
découverte de cette pédagogie
aujourd'hui j'ai profité d'un changement
de vie puisque j'ai quitté la région
parisienne pour cette belle ville de
bordeaux et génisses y ait une forme une
formation pour découvrir pédagogique
irait mais pour moi avec liberté il ya
donne une grosse partie théorique est
accompagné d'une partie stage donc j'ai
effectué un stage d'un an dans une
petite école montessori de 15 enfants de
3 à 6 ans découvrir le fonctionnement
d'une école de 15 ans flanc après avoir
enseigné dans des écoles de 100 200
voire 300 enfants
c'était un vrai choc pour moi une vraie
libération
j'ai découvert un environnement
favorable à échelle humaine qui respecte
le rythme enfants et qui sont adaptés à
ses besoins fondamentaux vous le but
lui donner envie d'apprendre le sens de
l'effort et l'autonomie toujours dans
cette école les enfants arrivés avec
plaisir et repartez avec le sourire les
éducatrices accompagner les enfants de
8h30 à 16h30
non stop pendant trois ans ça leur
permettait vraiment de connaître chaque
enfant le fonctionnement ses intérêts
ses forces ses faiblesses ses peurs ça
leur permettait de s'adapter vraiment
leur apprentissage et leur scolarité au
rythme de chacun pour autant une vraie
cohésion de groupe existaient les
enfants de 3 ans admirez un peu les plus
grands les plus grands été
responsabilisés vraie cohésion qui
existait beaucoup de bienveillance aussi
j'avais enfin trouvé la pédagogie qui
avait du sens pour moi dans cette petite
école
je me sentais épanouie et surtout libéré
délivré dans système éducatif classique
que j'ai connu petit durant lequel je me
suis pas ennuyé comme vous peut être
délivré dans un système éducatif qui ne
m'avait jamais finalement convenu à ce
moment là pour moi il n'était plus
envisage de envisageable de revenir dans
l'éducation nationale
j'avais envie d'aller plus loin dans la
libère dans la dans la libération de la
de l'éducation très vite j'ai choisi
j'ai pris la décision de créer ma
structure pour moi aussi laisser la
possibilité aux enfants d'exprimer leur
potentiel et de s'épanouir dans leur
scolarité
je souhaitais aider les enfants à
devenir des adultes autonomes et
responsables pour le monde de demain
alors je parle beaucoup d'autonomie mais
qu'est ce que c'est l'autonomie alors
selon le larousse
l'autonomie c'est la capacité de
quelqu'un à être autonome à ne pas être
dépendant d'autrui c'est le caractère de
quelque chose qui fonctionne ou évoluent
indépendamment d'autres choses synonyme
indépendance liberté oui c'est bien cela
je souhaitais aider les enfants à ne pas
être dépendant d'autrui à pouvoir leur
permettre de créer leur personnalité
qu'ils soient indépendants un rôle des
parents nous laissons quand ils arrivent
sur notre planète n'est par définition
est par définition complètement
dépendant pour tous ses besoins
en grandissant l'enfant apprend par
beaucoup parole a répété répétition de
ce qu'il voit il regarde l'adulte il
apprend il essaye en arrivant à l'école
on demande aux enfants d'être très
autonome par rapport à leurs affaires
alors tu leurs activités scolaires mais
aussi par rapport à la relation d autres
à la séparation des parents
pour autant il n'a pas vraiment de
liberté vous connaissez la chanson à
8h30 mathématiques à 9h français à 10h
récréation les enfants doivent répondre
à des consignes un peu obscurs parfois
ils ont pas possibilité vraiment de
s'exprimer en dehors de ce cadre
le résultat est bien on est un petit à
petit la curiosité naturelle de l'enfant
en arrivant à l'école
il poste et herman et plein plein plein
de questions et pise
petit à petit ils se lassent les autres
où il vit d'école comme une contrainte
alors dans les écoles montessori c'est
tout le contraire
on libère on autorise les enfants sont
encouragés à être autonome
l'enfant n'a plus systématiquement
besoin que d'avoir le regard de l'adulte
l'aide de l'adulte et ça le rend heureux
il a aussi en liberté dans le choix des
activités
il a le droit de choisir l'activité
qu'il souhaite faire et puis il a aussi
le droit parfois de ne pas perdre
activités parce que oui de toute façon
forcer un enfant à faire apprendre et
les sons c'est la meilleure solution
pour qu'ils ne la retiennent pas alors
maintenant je vais vous demander de vous
projeter dans des situations que je vais
vous décrire et vous questionnez sur le
ressenti que cela implique imaginez tout
d'abord un projet professionnel que vous
aurez choisi
comparer le un projet professionnel
imposé est-ce que vous rencontrez la
même motivation dans ces deux projets
ensuite penser à un loisir que vous
auriez envie de découvrir ça peut être
une nouvelle co compétences apprendre à
coudre apprendre une nouvelle langue
découvrir une activité sportive
alors peut-être que dans cette
découverte vous allez rencontrer des
difficultés
c'était peut-être plus 10 filtres
difficile que prévu mais pour autant
vous l'avez choisie vous êtes motivé
vous allez aller jusqu'au bout
est-ce que la satisfaction que cela vous
apporte au final serait la même que pour
une activité imposer un apprentissage
imposer enfin dernier cas de figure vous
vous avez dans votre cas de
professionnels certainement déjà eu
était obligé assister à une formation à
une conférence où une réunion auquel
vous n'aviez pas du tout envie qu'on
parle à une formation que vous aurez
choisi
est ce que vous avez retenu autant de
choses dans les deux cas alors je pense
que vous avez répondu plusieurs fois non
à des questions
et effectivement la motivation colonne
éprouve dans ces activités est vraiment
lié est bien plus importante pardon
quand c'est vous qui l'avez choisi la
liberté induit une motivation et de la
persévérance qui mène souvent à la
réussite et ce peu importe les
difficultés et bien pour les enfants
c'est pareil en enfants qui choisit san
afin de motiver qui persévèrent il est
fier de réussir et il a confiance en
lui-même les apprentissages également
sont bien plus solide puisque la mémoire
à long terme est plus utilisé au sein du
groupe oc envoie son de l'intérêt
puisque les enfants sont moins dans la
compétition et donc ils sont - ils sont
plus coopératifs plus empathique et plus
coopératif en enfants autonomes qu'en
grandissant devient un adolescent
tonneaux c'est à dire c'est à dire en un
adolescent qui prend plus facilement des
initiatives
d'un point de vue scolaire il est plus
organisée plus curieux monter encore une
marche un enfant puis un adolescent
autonome ça devient un adulte autonome
c'est-à-dire un adulte responsable de
ses actes qui entreprenants et qui aura
le sens des initiatives
finalement c'est ce que l'on demande
dans la plupart des entreprises de nos
jours reste la question du comment
comment aider les enfants à être
autonome
je vais vous utilisez les citations de
maria montessori pour illustrer mes
propos n'est déjà mais un enfant à faire
une tâche qu'il se sent capable
d'accomplir seul
donc on voit sur la photo une la photo
d'une petite fille qui était de mettre
les chaussures
alors oui un enfant il a envie d'essayer
faire plein de choses mettre les
chaussures s'habiller manger tout seul
quand il fait tout seul
évidemment c'est plus long mais aussi
c'est un peu moins bien fait mais pour
autant s'il faut l'encourager dans ce
sens
c'est en encourageant cette prise
initiative qu'il va continuer à en faire
et surtout pas casser cet élan spontané
évidemment il ya des limites la sécurité
de l'enfant avant tout on à l'adulte à
un regard un peu plus aguerri sur ce
sujet donc un enfant qui soit habillé
seuls s'ils veulent
si le maître un t-shirt art qui fait
moins 10 dehors l'adultère va devoir
intervenir
l'enfant nous aident à l'aider à agir
seul
effectivement tout petit enfant n'a pas
la capacité motrice à tout faire seul
mais l'adulte peut tout à fait l'aider à
apprendre à élargir son catalogue de
gestes botteur dans les écoles
montessori comme vous voulez voir sur la
photo
or on propose des petits plateaux
d'activités donc la petite fille est en
train d'apprendre ouvrir et fermer des
boîtes et bien en s'entraînant de cette
manière le jour où elle aura à ouvrir
son pot de confiture tout seul elle va y
arriver
et l on fera très contente il ne s'agit
pas d'abandonner l'enfant à lui-même
pour qu'il fasse ce qu'il veut mais de
lui proposer un milieu où ils puissent
agir librement
effectivement il est souvent reproché
aux écoles montessori de laisser
l'enfant à l'abandon de laisser faire
tout seul et des attentes que ce soit
qu'ils apprennent alors non c'est pas
forcément comme ça que ça fonctionne
maria montessori a élaboré un matériel
pédagogique en a déjà parlé qui permet à
l'enfant d'apprendre donc s'élancer
l'adulte qui apporte matériel qui va
l'aider à apprendre mais au sein de
votre domicile
il y a aussi quelque chose qui a une
grande importance dans l'autonomie de
l'enfant
le mobilier si l'enfant n'atteint pas
ses affaires il ne pourra pas être
autonome par rapport à ça c'est aussi
simple que ça l'enfant est un individu
unique pour apprendre il doit se sentir
accepté et met en sécurité et acteur
d'un environnement qu'ils encouragent le
nourrit et le soutien l'adulte garde un
rôle central dans le développement de
l'enfant
c'est grâce à sa présence et son
comportement que l'enfant se sont en
sécurité et qu'il se sent capable de
faire qu'ils seront capables qu'il est
important
en conclusion
j'aimerais vraiment insisté sur la
nécessité pour tous les adultes
d'accorder de la confiance aux enfants
le jeune l'enfant est par nature curieux
ils cherchent à apprendre à découvrir à
explorer il est primordial que l'adulte
encourage toujours les enfants a essayé
par eux-mêmes à être autonome
entreprendre a essayé cela permet de
conserver la curiosité naturelle de
l'enfant qui est central dans l' envie
d'apprendre
pour terminer je vais encore prendre une
petite phrase et maria montessori
libérer le potentiel de l'enfant et vous
transformerez le monde avec lui
et oui et si nous les verrions le
potentiel de l'enfant merci
[Applaudissements]